hey welcome to the monitor as always I
am Peter Rubin senior editor at Wired I
don't know can you hear this he's
slapping my thigh taping an episode of
hee haw on commercial break so that's
what I'm doing there this week we have a
movie that is actually pushing stop
animation forward you didn't think it
could happen but it can we are talking
about a video game that lets you be as
hard boiled as you want to be but first
we are talking about my most anticipated
comic book of the year did I just say
that i actually did unbidden
superlatives coming from my mouth I
didn't know that was going to happen but
now that I've said it I realized that
it's true that comic book is the
victories by michael avon oeming who you
may know for his work as co-creator and
artist on powers which is one of my
favorite comic book series of all time
he also did mice Templar this is the
first one-man show creating writing and
doing the art on it it has a little bit
in common I suppose with powers and
maybe even with watchman in the sense
that it deals with superheroes and their
human foibles and idiosyncrasies this is
by no means untrodden for comic books
but what's interesting about it is
michael avon oeming is coming to it as a
as a series to kind of unpack his years
spent in therapy he's been very up front
about this in interviews and so it
brings a very kind of therapeutic lens
through which to examine the whole
superhero thing and the vigilante thing
I've always loved his art style and I'm
really looking forward to more of his
writing you know I've seen the preview
of the first issue by the time you see
this i will have purchased and read the
entirety of the first issue but it is
out this week from dark horse it is a
five-issue miniseries that is seems to
be concentrating on one hero in the six
superhero group called the victories so
hopefully we'll have many more issues to
look forward to after this first
miniseries but it has already jumped to
the top of my pull list which if you are
not a comic book reader you should know
that is not as nasty as it sounds but
enough about comic books let's talk
about video games out this week with our
man on the scene in Hong Kong
okay thank you now why did I thank you
I'm the one who went to Hong Kong for
this but anyway as you know video games
get a little slow in the summertime one
might actually say that the release
calendar sucks but that is not always
the case things start ramping up a
little bit in August in the next week or
two we have Darksiders 2 and then in
September Borderlands 2 comes out but
this week we have Sleeping Dogs an act
third-person action-adventure game from
united front games in canada being
published by Square Enix it is of course
based on Hong Kong action cinema John
Woo titles like a better tomorrow or
hard-boiled or movies like the infernal
affairs trilogy which was remade in the
States as the departed which we all know
and love but the dev team from united
front took a number of trips to Hong
Kong they actually had a guide to get
them inside the structure of the triad
so it is a game that is about an
undercover cop who goes into the Triads
to try to bring them down from the
inside it is a tale as old as Hong Kong
action cinema itself and it is being
used to great effect in Sleeping Dogs
there are some really fun game mechanics
and really cool driving sequences in the
game and a nice open world feel so
there's a lot of varied play and it's a
lot of fun and it's it's a sizable game
so it should get you through until the
game release calendar starts picking
back up but that is it united front
games sleeping dogs out this week pick
that up back to you
okay thank you for that let's talk about
animation for a second because
paranorman is coming up this weekend I
love animated movies and I love Pixar
stuff and Dreamworks tough as much as
the next person but I also sometimes
kind of Miss the the stop-motion
techniques of the animation of my
childhood hasn't been a lot of it in
recent years aardman in England does it
Nick Park who was behind wallace and
gromit which you probably know and love
they made chicken run a number of years
ago and there was a wallace and gromit
movie and there was the Pirates movie
which came out earlier this year they do
very kind of traditional claymation II
stop motion stuff but like estudios
based in oregon in 2009 they make
Coraline and they began this process of
using some 3d printed parts which is
very in line with the whole wired maker
thing so what they started with Coraline
they really ramped up and are going full
throttle with on ParaNorman so many of
the of the facial parts were worth 3d
printed and there are so many
interchangeable parts and the way that
they made the facial animations and the
expressions on the many characters it's
really incredible we actually have a
feature in our August issue written by
wires Kaitlin Roper and edited by the
guy who hosts the monitor I forget his
name but it takes you inside the
techniques and and kind of runs the
numbers on these things and it is just
so unbelievably intricate and complex
and as such a mind-boggling task what
they've been able to do but even beyond
that the story itself is fantastic it's
it's spooky with a lot of humor it's
about a kid who has to save his town
from a curse so if you've seen the
trailers during the Olympics and you
probably have you get that there are
zombies and monsters and things like
that it is a lot of fun and we haven't
been seeing a lot of these movies this
summer so it's nice to have kind of a
kid adult spooky animated thing
Frankenweenie will be coming out later
this year but I'm more excited to be
honest about ParaNorman which is out
this weekend but that's it for the
monitor as always we will be back next
week with more pop culture in the
meantime feel free to email us at the
monitor at wired.com rage at us rage at
us or love us that's also good to we
always welcome that but we're taking
suggestions let us know what you think
we should be covering always listening
because that
what we do that's what the monitor is
about until then though inspirational
catchphrase here
you